everything in the body has some meaning
we're going to take a look starting at
the head and going all the way down to
the toes at some of the most interesting
body parts that have often been
categorized as maybe useless
auricular muscles some people have
muscles where they can wiggle their ears
a little bit these are rare we have
three on the outside so these are
Remnant auricular muscles that
originally had great functions
particularly with sound the way your dog
or your cat do even in many of the
monkeys our ancestors ears are able to
move a bit with sound but now they've
largely lost that function and they are
usually considered vestigial the term
vestigial comes from the Latin meaning
Footprints so there are structures that
were thought to be sort of footprints in
time giving us little Clues to what came
before so we when we hear a sound do not
necessarily move our ears in that
direction we tend to move our entire
head towards the sound what's
interesting to show that it's still
hooked up Studies have shown that when
we hear a sound that brain areas that
deal with these muscles have some
activity Plica semilunaris
when you look at the medial side of the
eye area you're going to see a vertical
line here is the location next time you
look at a dog or a cat or a reptile
you'll notice that they don't have two
but they have three eyelids we have an
up we have a down they have one that
goes side to side that's the nictitating
membrane in this little fold is the
remnant we know we don't have it in our
closest relative the chimp and we don't
have it in ourselves it's a moistener
and apparently we have sufficient
moistening without needing that
wisdom teeth technically known as our
third molars you can see here they're
largely problematic in which they Bend
or twist and you have to go to the oral
surgeon to have them removed over the
eons of our evolutionary changes our
diet became very varied the molars are
grinding teeth for eating leaves and
vegetable type things we became more
omnivorous this is a gorilla and you can
see how the face is very forward in a
gorilla in the course of human evolution
our face became very flattened in our
molar teeth became shoved all the way
back the molars became squished in we
developed a very very pronounced chin
found only in Homo sapiens it's a
distinguishing feature of our species
and we're not exactly clear what made it
come about it's a byproduct it's called
a spandrel sometimes things occur in our
body that had no discrete meaning or
function
male nipples nipples are extremely
important structures they're important
for breastfeeding but why do I have a
nipple then the male nipple is not
useless it's highly stimulatable it is
an erogenous Zone and these are not
unimportant things by the way for
example dogs and cats they have multiple
nipples there's a developmental Ridge
where nipples appear that's called the
nipple line nipples can appear all along
a series of lines and you may find for
example that somebody has a nipple all
the way down in the pelvis or frequently
in the armpit is a bit of a throwback we
sometimes call it an atavism and that
term is usually used for something that
has missed a few Generations or
something that pops up due to an
interesting recombination of genes
body hair
we have hair but our hair is not densely
packed all over like our closest
relatives hairs Prime function is for
thermoregulation and it played very
vital part when our ancestors came from
forest-like environments helping to keep
heat in when it got too hot it kept heat
away we lost our hair the weather was
changing things were shifting on the
plains of Africa and our ancestors
started to go to Savannah's we were
starting to be bipedal we were starting
to be Hunters we were starting to learn
to run and the loss of hair helped us in
our active Lifestyles with sweating the
glands involved in sweatings are much
greater in us and it allows us to
maintain our temperatures better a hair
in our furry relatives had a purpose
with little babies being able to hang on
to it we think we still maintain the
little grasp reflex of newborns and that
has been related back to it certain
areas in primates particularly Apes
became hairless early on the face we do
a lot of signaling with our face so do
chimps so do gorillas we do retain some
hair on the top of our head in our anal
genital area and in our armpit area the
brain has to be kept somewhat cool hair
up there AIDS in cooling the area and
protecting it and that's why they seem
to be retained
erector pili muscles produce the effect
of Goosebumps here's the hair here's an
erector pili what they do when they're
stimulated is they contract they force
the hair to stand erect it'll Aid in the
skin responding to some type of threat
you'll get the hair stand up in the back
of your neck when this occurs in our
ancestors or your cat the hair will
become puffed up what is that puffiness
do it increases the appearance of your
size so it's a display feature as well
appendix
[Music]
this is called the cecum and this
worm-like structure coming off of it is
known as the appendix it's not useless
it's very useful because it was
removable the appendix was thought to be
vestigial and worse bad because it can
swell what we've learned over the last
few years is that the appendix has
helpful bacteria and assists the gut
when there are different problems and
diseases coccyx
[Music]
coccyx was our primitive tail here we
can look and see the vertebral column
the last three to five vertebrae that
comprise the little funky thing that
looks like a cuckoo's beak that's known
as the coccyx this is a vestigial
structure a distinguishing difference
between great apes and monkeys is that
none of the Apes have tails are ape
ancestors do not locomote the same way a
monkey does swinging through a tree they
locomote differently the more these
animals started to walk on all fours and
then with us to walk by penally the
Tails were not useful any longer and so
it was pushed to the side it became a
Vestige every once in a while pretty
rare due to an interesting recombination
of genes somebody is born with a tail
pyramidalis muscle if you look in the
mirror you will notice your six-pack I
don't have a six-pack anymore I never
had a six-pack this forms What's called
the rectus sheath we have a muscle
called the pyramidalis because of its
shape at one time it was thought to give
support to the abdomen very various
monkeys are shown to have it in us it's
become very small and we're not really
certain what it does we might have lost
it because of our unique mode of bipedal
locomotion every time we've modified our
locomotor Behavior certain muscles in
large certain muscles become less we
have a number of muscles in the body
that have become
largely vestigial they've shrunk their
function has shifted
[Music]
plantaris muscle we have a muscle in the
leg which has become largely vestigial
it's become just attended the plantaris
comes from the area of the knee comes
from the femur and goes all the way down
to have a separate tendon they are
larger in the Apes we have a number of
muscles in the body that have become
largely vestigial they've shrunk their
function has shifted flat feet
the human foot has been modified solely
for the purposes of ambulation for
running in order to do that we have a
double Arch system one Arch goes from
front to back we call this a
longitudinal Arc and another goes side
to side to reduce muscle usage this is
one reason why a chip or a gorilla
cannot emulate or run the way we can
they don't have double arches their feet
tend to be flatter and every once in a
while will have somebody who genetically
born with flat feet here's an individual
who is showing what we call PES planus
or flat feet The Arches sink when the
Arches sink the muscles that go
underneath it must fire so anybody with
flat feet has to use muscles to try to
pull those arches up up and that's very
expensive I'll also tell you how you can
damage your arches nobody ever
anticipated something like high heeled
shoes they're dangerous they're hurtful
and they work to destroy what Nature has
taken millions of years to create there
have been body ports that have
diminished greatly in function we have
things that we thought may have been
useless that we've discovered are very
useful our body is the culmination of
our history
[Music]